كما فد مراسل الجزيره بسقوط خمسه شهداء
واصابه عدد اخر في قصف اسرائيلي استهدف
ارضا زراعيه تؤوي عددا من النازحين شمال
رفح جنوبي قطاع
غزه معنا الان من رفح مراسل الجزيره هشام
زقوط وهشام رفح في بؤره النار كما مجمل
قطاع غزه بالرغم من انها المنطقه التي
يدعي جيش الاحتلال انها
امنه
بالفعل مياده رفح هي في بؤره النار والقصف
الاسرائيلي في كل يوم نرصد غارات
اسرائيليه تستهدف في جلها منازل مدنيه
فلسطينيه شقق سكنيه وايضا اراض زراعيه لجا
اليها النازحون وبالتالي هناك اعداد من
الشهداء والجرحى وهذا القصف يكون مكثفا من
بعد منتصف الليل وبالتالي جل الشهداء
والمصابين هم من النساء والاطفال لانهم
يلجؤون في ظل هذه الظروف وفي ظل ظل هذه
الحرب وايضا الاوضاع والاحوال الجويه
السيئه يلجؤون الى منازلهم مبكرا ربما من
بعد عند الساعه الثامنه او السابعه بتوقيت
فلسطين وبالتالي بعد منتصف الليل عندما
يشتد القصف الاسرائيلي فانهم يكونوا في
المنزل وهناك شهداء وجرحى كما جرى في شمال
رفح عندما قصفت الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه ودمرت منزلا وارضا زراعيه
بجانبها بجانبها وبالتالي كان هناك اعداد
من الشهداء الجرحى جراء هذا القصف العنيف
وربما في رفح لا يوجد لا شارع ولا ارض
زراعيه ولا اي مكان لا يوجد فيه نازحون
فلسطينيون وبالتالي هي مزدحمه عن بكره
ابيها عندما نتحدث ان سكان مدينه رفح
كانوا 300,000 واليوم هم مليون و300 ال
هذا يعني ان الاكتظاظ مش شديد للغايه
وهناك كثافه سكانيه ربما هي الاعلى في
العالم في مدينه رفح بسبب دا اعداد
النازحين الكبيره الذين يلجؤون الى رفح
ورفح مستمره في استقبال هؤلاء النازحين في
ظل استمرار القصف الاسرائيلي في خانيونس
في مناطق وسط قطاع غزه وفي كل مناطق قطاع
غزه يستمر القصف الاسرائيلي ولو توجهنا
جنوبا فخان يونس هي الان ربما من المناطق
الاكثر حده في القصف الاسرائيلي والاكثر
كثافه لا سما المناطق الشماليه ل المناطق
الجنوبيه لخان يونس وهذه المناطق باتت
تتعرض الى قصف عنيف منطقه جورت اللوت
منطقه قيزان النجار هاتين المنطقتين باتا
يتعرضان تتعرضان الى قصف عنيف من الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه هناك عمليه توغل جديده منح من
محور جديد في تلك المناطق وبالتالي القصف
يكون اعنف ربما ما زالت المناطق بن سيلا
وخزاعه والقرار وبسانيو الشرقيه لخان يونس
تتعرض الى قصف عنيف الحصار ما زال مستمر
ومتواصل على تلك المناطق لكن هذا المحور
الجديد يكون القصف فيه مكثفا الجيش
الاسرائيلي يواصل عمليات القصف يواصل
عمليه حصار النازحين في المدارس في
المدارس التابعه للاونروا او المدارس
العامه وبالتالي هناك اداد من الشهداء
والجارحى لم تستطع سيارات الاسعاف وطواقم
الدفاع المدني الوصول اليها في تلك
المناطق ايضا طائرات كواد كابتر اسرائيليه
تحلق في سماء تلك المناطق وربما هي تحلق
في سماء كافه مناطق قطاع غزه التي يتوغل
فيها الجيش الاسرائيلي تطلق النار على كل
من يحاول التحرك كل من يحاول الخروج حتى
على سي الاسعاف وطواقم الدفاع المدني هي
تطلق النار ايضا المناطق الوسطى مخيم
المغازي مخيم البريج تتعرض الى قصف عنيف
من المدفعيه ومن الطائرات ولا تستطيع حتى
طواقم الاسعاف وطواقم الدفاع المدني
التوجه الى تلك المناطق شكرا جزيلا لك من
رفح مراسل الجزيره هشام
زقو